Individuals was I describe us Mecca who
are saying when they say he wants to say
hi,
if you sweet individual and I have no
problems with other religions and I did
not want to be engaged with any politics
or any show or to link politics with
religion,
please leave me alone.
Right,
right,
right.
And now I wouldn't say it would be
the majority of Muslims worldwide.
I'm not sure you agree with that,
but it seems to me that it isn't self
evidently the case that the majority of
human beings are violent and warlike
and so my sense is is that given the
essential peace
peacefulness of most people,
they're going to take a look at the
Islamic doctrine and extract from it those
elements that are supportive
of that more individual piece,
but that still leaves open the question
of exactly what the doctrine means as a
set of motivational principles and that
seems to be a big part of the current
problem and also the need
for current discourse.
What I would hope is that it would be
possible to undertake a dialogue with
Islam,
let's say between Islam and the West
are between Islam and Judeo Christianity
and defined within Islam itself the
seeds that would enable that dialogue to
occur so that some sort of long term
negotiated conceptual and practical piece
could be attained.
But the more I've read about Islam,
the more difficult it is for me to
understand how that might be managed,
especially because of its,
well because of the war like tradition
that emerged from from Medina and then
moved outward ins at a
staggering rate from that.
And also the thing that's quite
quite disconcerting to me,
I mean it's not,
my Christianity hasn't been rife with
internal divisions like that between the
counselors and the Catholics,
but it also was the case that what you
might describe as the civil war that's
been occurring within Islam,
more or less started as far as I can tell,
more or less started that day that
Muhammad died and has never stopped since
then.
And that also seems to be,
well obviously it's a problem
for the Islamic community itself,
but it also seems to be a problem,
an increasing problem for the west because
we can't not be tangled up in that.
Yeah.
We,
we have to share the planet with one
fifth of humanity and it's very clear that
things have to change and it is the duty
of Muslims to change the theological
underpinnings of their religion.
And as far as I'm concerned,
this is being pushed by those that I
call them the farmers or modifiers.
Yeah.
And these are individuals who
maybe know a little bigger groups.
They are forming views and maybe
even being led by some nation states,
the leaders of countries who are low,
she'll before that change,
the big question is either going
to agree on what to change.
So what is this inbuilt into Islam is
this idea that does contract with God.
You,
I'm submit edits to the Corolla
and it's the same thing.
You know,
Mohammed boys is seen by Muslims as
infallible as somebody who never made a
mistake.
It's an uphill battle for those Muslims
inside this lamb who was seeking
modernization,
who was seeking the forearm to
agree on how to Eddie score.
How tough is to wait Muslims to accept
a truly peaceful right and a truly
tolerant idea of religion that
separates religion from politics,
respects women,
supposed to lie to people of other faiths
and people within Islam who wants to
leave their face.
So how do you get the theological
underpinnings for that?
Yeah,
that's the big button with him within his,
yeah.
Well,
yeah,
and the danger there too is that,
I mean we're not sort of thing is it
tempted often reform from within a
religious community.
One of the dangers there is that
instead of reforming it peacefully,
all you do is add another sect
to the,
for us secular people,
it seems from,
from a distance it seems
kind of easy to say,
well why don't they just separate
religion from politics and yeah,
we want to be here.
They just,
they can be the legislators
to look at it that way.
Too simplistic because then you get
the people who want to be religious.
These Medina subset,
what do you say?
The Medina Muslims,
an expression of his Muslim
less is to combat you to Islam.
Yeah.
To kill me as,
as opposed to if it's to
get women to cover up.
It's to keep the warning us
about live life to their,
yeah,
it,
it's the thing that's made me,
I wouldn't say nervous to some degree
from the perspective of someone who
analyzes totalitarian ideology because
the thing about totalitarian ideology is
it tends to be totalitarian,
right?
It's absolutely all consuming.
And yeah,
that's,
that's why also when I've been assessing,
cause I've done a fair bit of research
into comparative religion and,
and done my best to
expand my knowledge base.
And I've always had a hard time with Islam
in that regard because it's difficult
for me to extract out the purely religious
elements and to compare them to let's
say religious sentiments that have emerged
across across humankind and all sorts
of different times and eras.
And to separate that from
the political doctrine.
And sometimes I'm tempted
to think more that Islam,
you know,
broadly and vaguely speaking,
is something much more like a political
movement than it is in fact like a
religious movement.
It is a political theory and
it's a political movement.
It started out even in
Mecca in the early days,
come to my daughter.
It was a political message.
It wasn't,
it just has religious message,
right?
Even in the early days in
McAfee was absolute is Islam
by its nature is absolute
complete and total submission
of the individual to God.
And then Medina Mohammed then
came around with a political,
a blueprint for how society ought to live.
The relationship between
the individual and God.
There's relationship
between men and women.
It has been this relationship
between parent and child,
the relationship between the government
and the subjects and their duties.
It has a court system.
It has a military sisters.
So from its very beginnings is like,
it was more of a political theory.
There was at religion,
as we understand the agent today.